c'est une tradition Vatican met ses
prières de l'Angélus pour marquer le
nouvel an des cérémonies qui cette année
prennent un sens particulier le pape
François a de nouveau souligné la mort
de son prédécesseur sont venus la veille
le papa
cueillir devant la dépouille de Benoît
XVI premier pape et mérite de l'histoire
depuis sa renonciation il y a presque
neuf ans deux papes ont cohabité au
Vatican c'est vrai qu'ils sont très
différentes sont très différents par
tempérament culture mais en même temps
Benoît 16 à préparer le terrain y
compris avec sa renonciation cette
experte évoque notamment ses
interventions à propos des élus sexuels
et des scandales financiers secouant le
Vatican des dossiers qui ont par
ailleurs minés le pontificat de Benoît
Salz sur la place Saint-Pierre certains
croyantes tiennent à rendre hommage à ce
pape plus discret que son prédécesseur
Jean-Paul II ou encore son successeur
François
il a beaucoup fait pour l'Église
catholique 17 hommes parce que c'était
quelqu'un qui était assez profond qui
avait
quittéologiquement et était
quelqu'un très important et
après je trouve qu'il a eu la dignité de
passer la main
beaucoup ont été marqués par cette
démission surprise de 2013 un geste qui
n'avait pas été posé depuis plusieurs
centaines d'années mais l'ancien sous
réponsif ne faisait pas non plus
l'unanimité
rappelle qu'il était conservateur alors
qu'elle croit que l'Église devrait être
plus progressiste le départ de Benoît
XVI permettra de c'est la son successeur
François de réformer davantage
l'institution c'est possible croire en
île d'affaires auto en soit quelque part
aura les mains un peu plus libre bon ce
n'est pas très élégant je suis sûr que
François souffre de la mort de Benoît
XVI mais c'est vrai que il y a peut-être
des choses qui n'a pas osé faire par
respect pour son prédécesseur mais leur
est avant tout aux hommages jeudi c'est
le pape François qui présidentera les
funérailles de son prédécesseur Benoît
Saez sur la place Saint-Pierre une scène
qui n'avait jamais été vu dans la longue
histoire de l'Église catholique ici
Raphaël Bouvier au clair Radio-Canada à
Rome